- Hi, I'm Salman Khan,
founder of the Khan Academy.
- And I'm Caroline Hu Flexer,
founder of Duck Duck Moose.
- And we have a very
exciting announcement today.
As you probably know, Khan
Academy is a not-for-profit
with a mission of a free
world-class education
for anyone anywhere.
And we've always viewed
core to our mission
of how do we, how do we meet the needs
of our youngest learners,
of kids in preschool
or who might be in kindergarten.
And whenever we thought
about this in the past,
we always looked to Duck Duck Moose
as really the best company out there.
I'm a father of young children,
and they, to some degree,
grew up on these apps.
And so it was very exciting
when Caroline and her team
reached out to us and
propose that we join forces.
- We're thrilled to be
joining Khan Academy.
Duck Duck Moose is an indie
developer, and originally,
we started designing
apps for our own children
and now we have 21 early-learning apps.
And we've always been a
mission-driven company
concerned about kids and education,
trying to make the biggest impact,
and I think this is why
this is so exciting for us.
Being part of a larger nonprofit
where we can really make an impact
on kids all around the world.
- And you already have an
incredible suite of 21 apps
which now are going to be
- Free!
- [Khan] Free. And really free.
Not download and then try, truly free
because we want young
children all over the world
to be able to have
access to this learning.
And as a reminder to you,
the only way we're able to do this
is with philanthropic support.
So, if you're a big
supporter of this vision,
please think about donating.
So, as you can imagine,
we're all very excited
that now Duck Duck Moose,
the Duck Duck Moose team,
is now part of the
not-for-profit Khan Academy.
And keep a lookout for what's to come
because these 21 apps
are just the beginning.
We have some fun plans ahead of us.
- Absolutely.